yes i know we're moving into dangerous
territory here reviewing a video card
that's likely to be as difficult to buy
as just about every other one
and a perfectly valid question is this
why should nvidia release an rtx 3080 ti
if you can't even buy the vanilla 3080
well the official explanation is this
different cards come off the production
line with different levels of quality
and they are binned for different
product tears 3080 3090 and now 3080 ti
all use the same ga102 chip but the
processors are graded and allocated to
each product line the official
explanation then is that 3080 ti chips
were always reserved to be the 3080 ti
so in theory then the more ga-102
products out there the more gpus there
are physically available to buy so what
to make of the 3080ti as a product then
well first impressions are that well
physically at least this is totally
identical to the rtx 3080 when looking
at the founders card anyway it's the
same cooler design the same custom power
input even the same color now we've
already seen this once before nvidia
released a 3060 ti that's using the same
design as 3070 but they did tweak the
color scheme not so this time as far as
i can tell the only difference is the ti
logo stands to reason really after all
it is the same chip inside at the end of
the day
however you can really think of the
3080ti as a hybrid product of sorts the
cooler design from the 3080 but a lot
more of the internals
and the internal design of the 3090.
so yeah let's take a look at the specs
table here if we consider the 3090 as
the king of all of the ga102 based gpus
rtx 3080 ti has almost 98 of the shading
hardware of the so-called bf gpu
dwarfing the equivalent 83 of the rtx
the ti also gets the full 384 bit memory
interface of the 3090 up against the
3080s 320 bit bus therefore there's also
quite a big bump to memory bandwidth a
full 20 increase actually
the reduced amount of cuda cores
compared to 3090 does see a small drop
in bandwidth compared to the gpu king
though
memory nvidia sticks to the top end ti
playbook harving the titans or rather
the 90 series cards allocation 12 gigs
it is then of the g6x variety it's still
lacking compared to amd's 16 gigabytes
on its big navi cards but only 12 or 24
gig options are effectively available on
a 384 bit interface
boost clock on the new ti is lower than
both 3090 and 3080 but the 1665
megahertz clock here is as usual
conservative control at 4k ran between
1.7 to 1.8 gigahertz assassin's creed
valhalla even hit 1.9 but relatively
speaking it looks like it is a touch
slower than both 3080 and 3090 here
power though wow i remember saying that
the rtx 3080 was power hungry with its
demands for 320 watts the 3080ti matches
30 90 spec here at 350.
can the founders cooler handle it we had
a look at two samples one was absolutely
fine the other could see fans spin up
loudly under load and i do wonder
whether the silicon bear wasn't quite of
the same grade requiring more heavy duty
cooling for its part nvidia reckons that
it's an outlier and that performance
should be on par with an rtx 3080 which
to be fair is entirely consistent with
the other sample that we looked at but
really there's not much more to say
about the fit and finish of the rtx 3080
ti it's familiar territory really
internally it's much closer to a 3090
than a 3080 while on the exterior well
speaks of itself really doesn't it i
suppose i could talk about msrps for a
moment i guess
1499 for the 3090 plays 11.99 for the
3080ti then there's the 699 rtx 3080. i
mean in terms of price versus
performance and assuming msrps or
anything close to them were attainable
3080 is easily the pick of the crop but
both 3080ti and 3090 remain the faster
products it's just that even at msrp
the value is kind of questionable on
those super high end offerings
and i guess that's borne out by the
performance data right i'm benching at
4k here though 1440p and 1080p data is
available in the eurogamer review linked
in the video description below in doom
eternal here there's an 11 performance
lead for the 3080ti over vanilla 3080
while the 1390 hands in a poultry extra
percentage point of performance 3080 ti
also delivers around an eight point lead
over amd's 6900 xt when your minimum
frame rates are so high though it's hard
to tell the difference and you'll note
that the graph lines on frame time there
would require ultra magnification to
tell much of a difference if we look at
prior generations though 3080ti is a
good 55 percent faster than 2080 ti
while the comparisons against 1080 ti on
this title are mind-bending i guess we
should remember that 1080 ti was much
cheaper though back in the day even
inflation adjusted but even so 3080
pretty much the same price and it
blitzes it borderlands 3 does seem to
like compute and to scale with it 3080
ti beats 3080 by just over 12 percent
while the 3090 is faster than the new ti
by around three points which is pretty
much the biggest uplift you're going to
see between the two highest end ampere
offerings in rasterization performance
at fact 6900 xt is being on par with
1390 so 3080 ti is just a touch slower
for the record gen on-gen scalability is
still around 55 2080 ti to 3080 ti but
this time the 1080 ti the pascal card
can hold its own a little more
effectively there's a 2.26 multiplier to
performance when comparing the new gpu
to the old one shadow the tomb raider
and what i find quite interesting is
that these days the 3080 runs this game
as fast as the 3090 did at launch
meaning that the 3080ti notionally
sounds faster now this sounds odd right
but that's the benefit of driver
revisions when we re-bench the 3090 it's
just under 2 percent faster and it's
some way ahead of
xt
gen on gen comparisons a 44 booster
performance over 2080 ti and a 2.4 times
multiplier to frame rate versus gtx 1080
ti
bit of an interesting point though
whatever optimizations were made to the
driver weren't just applied to the new
ampere card i saw similar performance
uplifts with 2080 ti as well
same thing for death stranding where
i've typically referred to it being amd
friendly that's still the case but now
via driver optimizations i noticed that
both turing and ampere cards now run the
game a little better than before there's
a nine percentage point lead for 3080 ti
over 3080 while 3090 adds a mere 2.7 to
the ti's tally this puts the high-end
geforce cards effectively on par with
amd's best i don't have 1080 ti data for
this one it kept crashing but the 3080ti
is 39 faster than the 2080 ti on this
one
remedies control next no new boost to
performance via driver optimizations
here that i could see and it doesn't
really need it a vanilla 3080 is 10
points to the better over 6900 xt while
3080ti has a 12 point lead over its
standard sibling 3090 comparisons well a
1.7
lead over the ti
outside of the margin of error but not
by much
this is another game where the gen on
gen boosts are appreciable though 3080
ti is 49 faster than 2080 ti founders to
founders and that does include the 2080
ti's factory overclock
there's a 2.7 times improvement to
performance up against 1080 ti
so look i think these numbers are quite
profound really when you think about it
pascal cards are the ones most likely to
be replaced right so the increase to
performance there is going to be pretty
huge that said the 2080 ti is still a
terrific gpu
so i could go on really but there's not
really so much else to tell a 3080 ti is
typically 9 to 13 faster than the 3080
in rasterization tests and the 1390
always manages to inch ahead albeit by
very very small margins performance
differentials up against the amd rx 6900
xt vary but it's always there or
thereabouts in most of our tests and
it's notionally cheaper of course but
it's not really comparable when it comes
to rate racing performance where amd is
far further back in development than
nvidia and where basically all of the
available games were optimized on
geforce hardware
benching at 1440p here with no smart
upscaling techniques in play battlefield
5 which is pretty heavy with rt
reflections shows just a 7 point lead
for 3080 ti over 3080 while 3090 is a
couple of points to the better against
the new ti offering
even with resizable bar active on amd
and inactive on nvidia 3080ti is still
30.5 percent faster with rebar off on
both the gap extends to 45
metro exodus a curious one this again
just a seven point lead for 3080 ti over
30 80 while the 1390 still commands a
larger than average advantage 6.7 in my
tests again amd is far behind here with
3080ti outpointing it by 37
i should stress that this is the
non-enhanced version of exodus we'll be
updating our test bench suite in the
fullness of time finally control again i
see the 3090 punching above its weight
compared to rasterized performance with
the bf gpu delivering a 6 point lead
over the 3080 ti and again the ti is
just seven percentage points ahead of
the vanilla 3080 so this is kind of
curious as pretty much all of the raid
facing tests see the ti sit between the
standard 3080 and 3090 not skewed
towards the higher end offering as we
see in rasterization analysis we'll end
the performance test with a quick look
at resizable bar all of the tests we've
seen so far have been with this off on
both nvidia and amd hardware
now resizable bar is only available with
some motherboard and cpu combinations
effectively rebar allows the cpu to
address gpu memory far more efficiently
and this can produce some impressive
performance wins now i didn't look at
this in a huge amount of depth but
assassin's creed valhalla is interesting
at both 4k and 1440p resolutions i
charted a 5.5 lead with rebar active
this would likely rise at 1080p but come
on i find the concept of extreme gpus
running at full hd to be kind of
ridiculous
borderlands 3 was interesting i saw much
more instability in benchmark runs with
rebar active and you can see the stutter
on the frame time graphs there
and while this stutter can intrude into
the benchmark when rebar isn't active i
simply couldn't get rid of it when it
was enabled
run after run i'd still see the same
stutters there's no real win at 4k with
rebar active and only a 3.4 percentage
point lead at 1440p
finally control this does seem to be on
the list of supported titles but i
actually saw a regression in performance
here like seven or eight percent
so yeah not recommended for this title
now i'm going to add a gigantic caveat
to these results by saying that i'm
using an intel cpu core i9 10900k with
an asus board that does allow for
resizable bar
typically ryzen 5000 seems to be used
for benchmarks and i note that even
nvidia itself now uses a ryzen setup for
benchmarking in its own reviewers guide
so maybe it's my system that's not
optimal here but yeah i guess that's
everything i've got to say about 3080 ti
performance in detail and with that
being the case let's round everything up
then
there are a few surprises really with
the rtx 3080 ti
it feds the path of prior ti releases
this time nipping and tucking at 90
series spec as opposed to what would
have previously been called a titan you
lose a few shaders you half the ram but
you still get broadly equivalent
performance overall how equivalent well
the 1390 is between one to three percent
faster in our rasterization tests and
around six to seven percent faster with
raid facing
this is entirely consistent on the
rasterization side at least with the old
titan versus ti differentials right
thing is the situation is different this
time
now the non-ti-80 class product is using
the exact same chip as the absolute top
end offerings it's something we've not
seen since gtx 780 780 ti and the
original titan
and what that means is that the gap
between rtx 3080 and its far more
expensive siblings is much tighter than
it was between 2080 and 2080 ti
the circa 25 to 35 percentage point
difference is now more like 9 to 13
percent on average and it can even be
lower on games with traditionally poor
scalability like assassin's creed
odyssey here benched at 4k
meanwhile the gap in memory allocation
has also narrowed the three gigabyte
increase seen between 10 series and 20
series 80 cards compared to their ti
counterparts is now 2 gigabytes instead
it's difficult to avoid the conclusion
that you're getting the lion's share of
the experience with the standard 3080
meanwhile for high-end content creators
well personally speaking you'd have to
prize the 24 gigabyte rtx 3090 or indeed
the older titan rtx out of my cold dead
hands before i trade it for a 12 gig
card when it comes to high-end 4k
production or just insanely complex
premiere timelines in general
video memory is king
ultimately what you're left with then is
a halo product that's got more in common
with the extreme offerings of old a
relatively small amount of extra
performance for a whole lot more money
if this were a sane world where gpus
could be bought at msrp i think it's
fair to say that amd would still be in
the game with 6900 xt i think overall
3080 ti is on par or faster
but really it's the rate facing support
and dlss that would justify the extra
money in comparison to that
thing is
well dlss kind of makes the case for the
standard 3080 even stronger i guess
3080ti is indeed more of a halo product
the 3090 is great for content creation
at the high end but for this generation
at least value in the gaming space is
skewed much more towards the 80 part
but that's all from me for now so yeah
please do like subscribe share you know
the score and of course we've got a bell
and it's there to be wrong if you're
already subscribed doing so opens the
door to something both remarkable and
astonishing
instant notifications when we have a new
video for you as for the df supporter
program it's the full fat digital
foundry experience
bonus videos behind the scenes stuff
early access full-on df retro a close
relationship between the team and our
supporters we're proud of it we're proud
of the community we're building and i
invite you to partake plus of course
there's still the pristine quality video
downloads of everything we do that's all
from me for now thanks for making it all
the way to the end of this one if indeed
you did and just generally thanks for
watching and supporting digital foundry